pis pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
hier nous vous avons interrogé sur
l'amnistié fiscale accordée à médiapart
par une partie de votre majorité
madame la ministre de la culture a
répondu sur l'application du taux de tva
super réduit à la presse en ligne
mais elle n'a pas répondu sur l'amnistié
fiscale
autrement dit sur la légalisation d'une
fraude
alors monsieur le premier ni ce qu'elle
est votre position merci de votre
réponse claire par ailleurs le
gouvernement a annoncé la semaine
dernière une hausse inédite par son
ampleur des tarifs postaux pour la
presse magazine
cette décision était prise sans
concertation préalable avec les
professionnels qui ont découvert avec
stupeur l'énormité des augmentations
entre 30 et 50% dans les années à venir
pour les magazines hors information
politique et générale et ceci alors que
la presse vient de subir cinq années de
hausse continue
résultat des accords schwarz cette
augmentation qui a surpris tous les
acteurs est une véritable volte face qui
aura des conséquences désastreuses pour
les lecteurs d'abord qui vont payer plus
cher leur abonnement voir ne plus les
recevoir du tout pour la poste ensuite
qui va perdre un volume important de
magazines à distribuer au profit du
portage pour les éditeurs ensuite déjà
très fragilisée qui risquent
d'abandonner certains titres devenus non
roulante rentable et puis aussi pour la
filière toute entière qui risque encore
et encore de supprimer des emplois
d'imprimeur de brochures et de
journalistes
monsieur le premier ministre tous ces
magazines sont livrés par la pause sur
l'ensemble de nos territoires ruraux à
de nombreux lecteurs
confirmez-vous cette annonce qui menace
un équilibre déjà très précaire
merci si la parole est à madame fleur
pellerin mise de la culture et la
communication
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député j'ai dit hier très clairement
deux choses la première chose c'est que
le gouvernement est favorable à la
convergence des taux de tva de la presse
écrite et
de la presse en ligne et c'est la
position que nous défendons constamment
auprès de la commission européenne
c'est aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
avons fait voter une loi installant ce
nouveau taux de tva super réduit pour la
presse en ligne
mais j'ai dit aussi hier que dans la
dans l'intervalle
dans l'intervalle et avant que la
commission européenne se prononce sur
cette aune la loi doit s'appliquer
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement était opposé à cette
amnistie fiscale que vous avez évoqué
écouter la région les sujets de
transport postal
vous l'avez dit transport postal c'est
un service public est essentielle et
l'objectif du gouvernement c'est de
recentrer
là aussi nous l'avons dit clairement
l'aide au transport postal sur les
titres de presse qui concourent au débat
citoyen au savoir et à la connaissance
donc 2016 sera une année de transition
au cours de laquelle nous déterminerons
quels sont les titres qui dépendent qui
relève de la connaissance et du savoir
et ce qui relève du divertissement
les hausses tarifaires pour l'année 2016
hors inflation seront 2 0% pour les
titres à faibles ressources
publicitaires de 1 % pour les autres
titres d'information politique et
générale dit
ipg et de 3% pour le reste de la presse
en revanche la réforme que j'indiquais à
l'instant s'appliquera à compter de 2017
la à partir de cette année là les titres
à faibles ressources publicitaires et
les titres d'information politique et
générale qui sont au coeur de la
politique de soutien à la presse
connaîtront des hausses tarifaires très
modérée de 0 et de 1 % la presse de la
connaissance et du savoir bénéficiera
d'une tarification plus favorable que
celle du divertissement puisqu'elle sera
de 3% contre 5% pour la seconde
et j'ajoute que la compensation de
l'état versée à la poste sera stabilisée
pour ne pas fragiliser économiquement
l'opérateur postal vous voyez monsieur
le député ces tarifs seront prévisible
dans la durée
tu portable pour les éditeurs comme pour
l'opérateur postal mais nous assumons
que l'argent public aille plus que
jamais prioritairement à la presse
d'accès à la connaissance et au savoir
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
socialiste républicain et citoyen